[Music]
let's keep the conversation going with
political commentator and author of
don't burn this book dave rubin all
right dave i'm going to out you
until this is a quote until a few years
ago
i was a full-on leftist do you admit or
deny that you made that statement dave
oh i don't remember if i was sworn in by
your staff right before we went live
but yes i was a lefty you can actually
find
videos i'm not proud of it judge jeanine
uh but yeah you can find videos of me
i was a bernie supporter i was a lefty i
was on a far left youtube network
and you know the thing that kind of put
me on the map was that i started
saying hey guys the left we're no longer
acting liberally
we're no longer defending free speech
we're shouting everybody down we're
screaming
speakers off college campuses and
burning college campuses down
and and now that sort of has burst forth
into
all the chaos that we're seeing out of
the modern left right now
well interesting does that mean now that
you're going to leave
la in california and move to one of
those more
capitalist right-wing states red states
a wright state
oh man now i'm fully on trial here
well i can tell you this everyone that
i'm talking to in la and i do walk my
dog i'm not sure if it's legal or not
here in l.a and some other people are
walking their dogs and occasionally
you cross somebody when we're talking
and we
you know dave i got to stop you wait yes
why
can't you walk your dog no people are
pooping in the streets
in california why can't your dog poop in
the street but keep going
[Music]
well for the record most of the pooping
in the street is happening in san
francisco which
you know that was uh gavin newsom our
governor now he's the guy
that ruined san francisco he was the
mayor of san francisco but in any event
people
in california to directly answer your
question they are
everyone's kind of talking about it like
do we bail or do we stay and fight and
and truly
judging i i am not sure what i'm gonna
do you know there's this part of me
that's like
maybe it is too messed up here the
budgets the way they've ruined
everything the homelessness all of it
maybe it's too far gone and then there's
another part of me that that genuinely
is a fighter
and and i think if there's one silver
lining to everything going on
that you've been discussing with some of
your other guests tonight it's that
regular people who maybe aren't
particularly political who don't
really care about politics in a big way
who are just just trying to live their
lives
well you trap them in their houses for
two months and you tell them they can't
go to work you tell them they can't make
a living
you tell them oh there's no end in sight
and it's going to be august 1st and then
you know on july 28th we're going to
make it
november 5th you know the day after the
election or something i think regular
people are waking up to what
overreaching government is they're
waking up to what freedom is what
liberty is
what what individual rights are that we
have a right and a duty
to live our lives as we see fit and it's
not the government's responsibility
to keep us safe from everything that
that a government can't do that
actually well not a good government at
least
well but you know it's so interesting
but it it's almost like a full-court
press dave
it's not just that they're saying you
have to stay in your home what they're
also
saying is we're going to give you money
to stay in your home
you know where and you have to do it in
order to be safe i mean that it's almost
like it's
it's a movie that they figured it all
out you know remember that movie
wagged the dog where it was made up
about a a war that really wasn't war
and that's what they're doing here
they're creating a real
fear you know which is justified based
upon
coven but you know but now we're kind of
the curve is
we bend the curve the hospitals are not
overflowing and then they're saying
we'll give you money it's okay stay home
and now what's happening dave people now
who can in or in some states where they
can now go out they're like a little
worried i mean
it's learned behavior it's almost like
gee you know i don't know maybe i
shouldn't go
out now it's a full court press by the
left
and it's a left right issue and the fact
that americans who may never have been
political or now getting it
is is a good thing as you say it truly
is
well that is a good thing and this is
what the kids online call red pilling
when you
actually see the world for what it is
not what the media hands you
and and feeds you when you actually see
truth it's a reference
from neo in the movie the matrix and i
think what we're really seeing right now
is that people you know they don't want
to live like this we
all know everyone knows this everyone
with a couple neurons firing in their
brain
knows that life is about a little risk
you are you're going to break an arm
you're going to twist an ankle you might
be hit by a car or anything that you do
in business
it involves risk you could you can make
money lose money everything that is
worthwhile in life
is about risk and unfortunately what the
blue state governors are doing in effect
and i'm mostly talking about cuomo
and gavin newsom so new york and
california they're saying hey guys we're
going to
reduce all of your risk to nothing
except there's no such thing
as no risk and then to contrast that you
see these governors
like abbott and texas and desantis in
florida who are saying hey listen we
don't know the exact
perfect response to everything but we're
gonna try to let you live and then you
know what we'll look at the numbers
i'm sure you saw judge the the the video
by desantis when he's talking about the
numbers
and he's saying and we this is what we
did this is what we're gonna continue to
do
and that's actually how you should
govern so again the
the beauty here yep don't forget the
beauty here is that good people
are waking up to this stuff people that
normally wouldn't care all right
dave rubin love having you on thanks for
being with us
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell